hello everybody my name is markiplier  and welcome to chicken walk oh good god  I think I have those chicken testicles  hanging off my beak that's right here  and very disorienting for me oh hello  babies oh my god you are you want touch  beaks oh no time for that  we got to go but it's so cute booth no  Fox is gonna get you not on my watch Hey  look a watch booth okay I got enough for  another egg I'm gonna make another baby  cuz I'm just so vile hello hi the facts  what do I do about the babies no my  babies  it ain't my babies it ain't my babies I  have no will to live  you bastard you you're just reading a  log I'm gonna take the piss out of your  boy your stupid [ __ ]  ah your butt eat me  I got nothing to say about this game  hello oh hello babies talk chest in your  lovely punch you look good sailor smack  that thing is gonna kill me well until  its turn is over you can't really move